here's how it's going to happen take a
look at this story from the Sacramento
Bee California moved to shut down a
third state prison as inmate population
shrinks oh the inmate population is
shrinking is that because people aren't
committing crimes anymore
heck no
California there's not enough
right-wingers in California to be
prosecuted so yeah right so uh long
story short they're letting people out
they're not Prosecuting crimes anymore
we're seeing video after video after
video of people rating stores and that's
why there's no one in these in these in
these uh prisons so this is going to
lead to just a further and further
collapse so just a moment ago we're
talking about like norlink and why
people are going to want to plug their
brains in there's two potentials they'll
say hey you know what crime is a serious
problem but we don't want prisons right
that's what the left says how about we
give people a brain a neural link that
disables criminal Behavior oh didn't
they also say they could put people in
neural link and put them in prison for
like a hundred years or something so
they could experience 100 years wow that
was a movie no no no no that wasn't but
there are also some conversations we're
actually having that conversation like
that could be the future of Prisons oh
man you go insane oh yeah it would be
like the blink of an eye but for you
it's 100 years you'd come out just go
like solitary can find for 100 years and
you can't die you can't hurt yourself
like yeah that's torture it's beyond
torture that's crazy that's like sending
someone to Hell literally yeah literally
100 years which is the goal anyway well
sure so what so what's happening now
California shutting down a prison here
we go let me show you this video
is from our good friends of our clown
world let's take a look they're just
wear that I think they're at an Adidas
store and they're just grabbing big
mounds of clothes and they're just
walking out with it gotta have the mask
on though so you don't catch Kobe
welcome in the crown well I mean exactly
why the masses are there right like we
don't have to worry about the
authorities hold on like just because
you're stealing some doesn't mean you
want to get sick so true someone could
sneeze on you and I know some people out
there are like dude they're wearing
masks they don't get caught get caught
they're shutting down the prisons
they're not worried about getting caught
well did it at least
yeah yeah it's all good no worries it's
like 980 or something right yeah
something like that I don't know so I
don't know I don't know man look I don't
live in these cities yeah I moved out is
that a good thing or a bad thing that
people are fleeing these places good
um right now they're also talking about
uh giving people reparations in
California to the tune of I think nearly
600 uh billion dollars uh someone needs
to fact check me that but I heard that
but that's that's again it's just
absolutely absurd where you have George
Soros coming in setting up this these
District Attorneys and letting things go
to chaos uh this chaos I think is
deliberate I think that the major theme
of Robocop is kind of repeating itself
uh if you haven't seen the first movie
and you don't know what that movie's
about definitely just look at the same
synopsis of it and it will read like a
history lesson of what's actually
happening right now in all the major
cities it happened in Detroit Detroit's
been ravished been destroyed by a lot of
very powerful people and I think it's
happening everywhere else like in New
York City Los Angeles and and uh your
town soon if it's big enough I got an
idea tell me what you guys think
Universal basic income right we give
everybody 1500 bucks a month hear me out
hear me out all right I see you not in
Bryson but but go on but the moment you
accept the program you are disqualified
from voting interesting based I am now
with it you be having people like that
get them out of here let's get you know
well look like it's like a choice no
one's forcing us to vote they're just
saying like look we will we will we'll
take we'll give you some money you know
you can live and do your thing with it
you don't gotta you don't gotta work
you'll have this money you can buy food
and uh you can't vote
well Elon Musk has advocated for Ubi
yeah because he thinks uh ai's gonna
take over but wait a minute so did yay
yay did as well yeah he's calling for a
Ubi as well what for real yep yeah I
didn't even hear that I gotta talk I
gotta talk I gotta talk hey I gotta
style to you because nah we ain't doing
Ubi cuz come on bro and sustainable
government housing all you're doing is
incentivizing people to be lazy and not
want anything sure sure but you don't
get to vote oh no no if you add if you
toss that aspect in there now we talking
about something see right right right so
uh we could we could we could actually
do it it doesn't have to be Ubi it could
be any government program right if you
are accepting funds from the government
in any capacity you can't vote then
after you terminate that assistance and
then for any reason there's like a 30 to
60 day wait before you can re-register
to vote
I think people would be on board with
that and I think that actually solved a
lot of problems for real now the left
would be like what that's not fair you
can't do that you know but I gotta tell
you if you went to somebody and said
here's what we'll do we're gonna give
you 1500 1500 bucks cash per month sound
good but yeah but don't vote like that's
that's the deal they'll they'll say yes
I don't care sure no everybody I know
where I grew up but say yeah yeah they
don't vote like that anyway
but then think about ballot harvesting
yeah these people who don't actually
care all that much have someone come and
say fill that out no sure fine whatever
and then they they get that vote and
that person normally would not have gone
to vote so my my view of this is you're
not going to solve the problem uh
there's a Starship Troopers thing
service guarantee citizenship you
familiar with that never heard of it so
it's a book it's a movie and the idea is
that in order to vote you have to
provide some service to the community so
uh you're you're a civilian or a citizen
and uh citizens get to vote civilians
have all rights but don't vote so then
if you want to getting the right to vote
you either like join the military or you
do community service you have to do some
kind of service yeah to contribute and
that that to me makes a lot of sense yep
I don't know if I completely agree with
it in that structure but I was thinking
about like how would you actually do
something like this how about moving
forward we passed a bill saying if you
accept any government assistance while
you're on assistance you are ineligible
to vote well it used to be sort of like
that people you had their own land or
something like that to vote uh back but
this flips it you know yeah like you
don't got to own anything you can be a
homeless guy but you're not taking from
anybody else you're not you're not
taking a hand out or anything or or
assistance the way I see it is if there
are people who are not contributing to
the system but are voting they're going
to vote to extract from the system so if
we if we all say like we're going to
hook you up because we don't want you to
suffer or anything like that but you
don't get to vote into our system and
take our stuff then I think actually
typically honest the end result of that
would be the termination of these
programs yeah because the people who
aren't on them are gonna but but to be
fair the people who are not them might
be like don't terminate those programs
because it's the only thing that stops
these people from destroying everything
I think a lot of these programs need to
be reduced anyway like the snap program
is supposed to be nutritional yeah and
the number one thing people buy with
food stamps is soda chips snacks Nutter
Butters
that don't sound so nutritional my boy
look I've got poison that's literally
killing people I've gotten uh uh
EBT I don't think we call them food
stamps anymore whatever I've gotten that
stuff before years ago and uh it's you
you walk into a grocery store grab a
bunch of candy bars yep that's crazy to
me oh my aunt used to get 700 a month
wow yeah candy bars no she's 700 a month
in food stamps what she used to do is
she's probably watching this right now
and what she used to do is she was a
sale because you know I go my family was
middle class so middle class people they
the ones buying I mean if y'all know
that you can buy food stamps from people
my family was the one doing it you know
middle class people don't get any help
at all so she was a sale like half of it
because who needs 700 food stamps he was
a sale half of it
[Music]
that's what they do yo there there are
people who would hang out inside of
Chicago outside of like Aldi and they'll
they'll see you go and they'll be like
hey hey let me buy it for you and just
give just give me the cash yeah and then
most people are like I don't know what
this is I don't be involved but some
people would be like uh you give me 10
bucks on top no big done yeah what they
do is they sell you so basically they'll
give you a hundred dollars you can go to
the grocery store and spend a hundred
dollars and all you have to do is give
them 50. yep and that's how that's how a
lot of people on food that's been making
money you know I'm saying with us
obviously paying taxes as taxpayers
won't get nothing from it though see me
and my me and my friends though we were
smart what we would do is we would go to
ALDI and then we would as people were
loading up the groceries we would say
can we take the cart back for you and
they go you got it and then we get the
quarter because the Aldi cards are the
quarter in it so it was like they're
like you keep you take I don't want to
walk the card back you take care of it
and keep the quarter oh snap yeah
lifetime job yeah so when I was like I
was like 10 years old or whatever I was
that's how I'd buy Pokemon cards oh nice
yeah you just [ __ ] the cores and you
have a big thing of quarters because
people were like I don't care about the
quarter take the cart I gotta waste my
time yeah that's how I did creating jobs
that's right
there were a few times where it was
really funny where like me and my friend
are out and some guys like sure you can
bring the card back but don't forget to
give me back my quarter and then we were
like cancer
yeah uh uh I don't know where we're
going man like I was thinking about
the problem of people who vote who don't
care you know uh what do we see uh
Warnock wins in Georgia and I'm I like
does anybody really care a lot of people
are talking about Harmony Dylan she's
gonna run for RNC chair I think she'd be
way better than than you know whatever
else is going on at the RNC But
ultimately I'm just like yeah yeah been
there done that dude if Republicans
don't understand what's going on with
disinterested voters voting and they're
not changing the system or adapting to
it there's no point in arguing any
policy you got all of the people I would
argue who actually know politics they
probably vote a republican yeah then
you've got the liberal types who are
either actively lying or being lied to
voting for Democrats and then you have
people who don't know don't care voting
for Democrats because of ballot
harvesting and and other things like
that and Republicans are outside of the
game I'm seeing people tweet that I
think Josh Hawley tweeted something
where he's like he's like you got to
start advocating and getting people to
vote and it's just like bro it's valid
harvesting you go to the door you you
get them to felt the thing you get them
to sign off as your caregiver in the
states where it's legal and then you get
the votes and it doesn't matter what the
person thinks wants or otherwise they
don't know they don't care it's it's
ignorant people voting so how do we
solve for that well Democrats are never
going to let you uh take away someone
just make them ineligible to vote based
on their welfare status or whatever but
that does seem like the right way to do
it it's a choice no one's forcing you to
accept the money we're giving you money
we want we don't want you homeless and
suffering we also don't want you voting
into a system you're not contributing to
I think that's fair not only that a lot
of the reasons a lot of um
mainstream conservatives they give you
the taco points on why you know the
midterms think of how people want it if
you actually look at the exit polls from
the midterms it doesn't it doesn't have
that view uh Republicans actually gained
in every single voter group except for
homosexuals and um and unmarried women
those are the only two voter groups out
of every single one they flip they flip
unmarried men they flip married women uh
we gained in the 18 to 29 crowd uh but
we we didn't gain those too but you know
Republicans aren't smart because culture
is obviously I think about the host
politics I don't think it even matters
who the politicians correct because
we're operating out of hate no one cares
to listen to anybody else if they're on
supposed their political enemy that's
why we need president yay it's raw power
like I think an outsider has to come in
and destroy the system I don't know
about yay though
well I make a case for it on in the in
the white I let him make a case for it
and uh but I think an outsider is needed
like I I watch after Trump's speech
it was so boring he was so boring and uh
you know like when he started talking
about executing drug dealers and stuff
like I'm like I don't need another War
on Drugs I would argue that social media
is more powerful than politicians
especially uh yielding uh yielding power
yeah uh but uh are you starting the
first uh juice for yay uh campus it's
actually Jews for Jesus yeah Jesus
that's kind of a blasting you know
what's funny if people paid attention to
the culture the Republican party will
have a much better time but they're so
stupid if if you really watch when Trump
said he was running announced he was
running if you go look at all the
hip-hop laws and stuff like that the
comment section was I'm definitely
voting Trump oh yeah as soon as he said
that that that that drug in the comment
go right back to them same comments they
said dang he lost my vote in three
minutes to me it seemed like watching an
old band do Greatest Hits like Mick
Jagger getting trotted down and said
well Mick Jagger has more energy than
that but yeah I was just like
after that politician just doesn't
politicians don't matter anymore I'm
still waiting for the rally to still be
lit though yeah it's it's just raw power
yeah all it is right now there's no laws
there's no Norms it's just the excess of
power and what people are willing to
accept thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time